joker lose a shot at tennis history as
australia the port star i'm going to
read two of those stories about this guy
and can you pull up some of the tweets
uh uh in regards to uh joker so
nomak uh djokovic anti-vaccination
stance uh has cost him a potential
payday of 2.1 million dollars in a shot
at tennis history after the play lost
his battle to remain in australia and
was deported the
serbian
boarded a flight from melbourne
airport late sunday night after the
nation's federal court upheld the
decision to revoke his entry permit over
fears his presence would strengthen
anti-vaccination sentiment it wasn't up
to the court to decide on the merits of
the decision only whether it was uh
illogical or legally unreasonable
unreasonable the player could face a
three-year ban from entering australia
but the prohibition may be waived if
there's uh under compelling
circumstances okay
so this whole situation of him what
people don't realize is i think this
would have caught this would have made
him the greatest of all time by winning
can you see who has the most majors in
texas i think they're all tied up
right federer djokovic
yeah and and if he wins he would have
been number one he almost won one like
two three months ago like he went second
place because the other guy beat him
right by the way that would be on
his winning record against him
individually he has a winning record
against federer individually he has a
winning record against all individually
so if he also has the most majors then
the argument starts to go in his favor
that he's the goat yeah and you're a
tennis player so you would know this
stuff you follow the subject yeah there
you go so 20 20 20
uh total six wimbledon eight uh uh for
federal okay so that's that part now go
to what some people have to say about
this and i want to get our panel here to
see what their thoughts are so uh uh
who's this law girl who is this person
do we know who this person is just a
user
okay djokovic cannot visit us australia
for three years we are we are the only
country that thinks it's okay to lock
out the number one tennis player on the
brink of being the best in the world not
because he's a health risk but because
he might make the ninety percent of its
citizens already backs not get a booster
so go to the next to it let's read a few
of these guys um make it bigger okay
joker is great tennis player he's a
great tennis mia pharaoh it's a great
tennis player but he lied and worse he
knowingly exposed people to covet had it
with them and every other arrogant
entitled person they're all dangerous in
one way or another there you go next one
is pierce morgan breaking
covet rule cheat immigration from liar
and anti-vaxxer icon novak djokovic
loses final appeal against deportation
and will be thrown out of australia
without being able to compete in aussie
open look at that picture yeah melbourne
right above him and go to the next one
there uh
uh ben who's is from ben
dominic
i feel like australia underestimates how
this novak djokovic incident has grown
to tar the entire nation as
fundamentally anti-freedom and a place
you should not visit for a long time to
come as a tennis player yourself what do
you think about this story
uh i look i i think at this point
djokovic is a champion not just of
tennis but of freedom i mean he's he is
he is pushing for uh personal individual
freedom to be able to make your own
decisions
um
the man is healthy the man is currently
healthy and he's not he's prohibited
from playing from staying in the country
from playing the tournament why what is
the reason for that there's rules
everybody has to follow the rules but
are the rules stupid or are they
reasonable
um you know if somebody's healthy
and if he gets the vax he can still
spread kovid
and people can still get it
then why is he prohibited from playing
just because he doesn't have it as his
individual choice the man's currently
healthy if he passes a covid test and
he's covet free when he walks into the
stadium why can't he play
that's my question but um you know he
was willing to put i mean look if he
wins this tournament which he was
actually fairly likely to win it um he's
the best player in the world right now
and he's won the australian open how
many times nine times maybe i think it's
like it's his right hand he's more than
any other like how does the french open
he's got the one he's most likely to win
he'd win three and a half million
dollars um you know the fact that he's
taken the stance could potentially cost
him his sponsorships lacoste is looking
into whether or not they're going to
continue to have a relationship get out
of here he makes 30 million a year on on
sponsorships so that's i mean that's his
primary income right is his sponsor so
he put a lot at risk here to be able to
stand by a conviction i respect that um
and i and i'm disappointed in other
players who are piling on to him saying
you know he's selfish any major player
andy murray uh nadal's had comments now
doll has been it's almost that hard on
him yeah
he basically said the tournament is
bigger than any one person you know the
focus needs to not be on him but he also
said he knew the rules before he showed
up he knew the rules he should have
followed the rules you know we all had
to follow the rules he's he's not he's
not special he's not an exception i
think 98 he said all of that 100 players
are vast in the
they're making life easier for
themselves and and you know it it it you
know you have a choice to make you you
have to pay there's a sacrifice now and
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to make it extremely costly to
not go along with the program and the
question is does the program even make
sense
adam what are your thoughts on this
story
well look
i think and i've actually asked multiple
friends of mine who played tennis and
actually played
against federer you know these types of
like legitimate people
and there's a couple different angles
that go here on the actual australia
like he did lie and you know mishandle
this and it was you know i forgot to do
this and he did show up to a freaking
photo shoot while having kovid so
he could have handled it better i will
give you a different perspective
if you asked everyone in the world
everyone around here who are the best
tenor player most people would say
federer okay most people would even say
nadal i don't know if
i think
nadal and federer specifically have such
a grasp on who is the best tennis player
because they're more likeable and have a
bigger persona and just
their personality is more djokovic i
feel like he doesn't have as much of and
your tennis player
as much
you know likeability within the tennis
world like we actually had like he's
tied as the or the greatest ever tied
but nobody i don't think really
understood that so i feel like there's a
part of him
that even with covid wants to get out
there win become the great to come to go
to you know become the goat
but i don't know if he has the
likability of you ever seen his
interviews have you ever seen him do
interviews
not like i can tell you a lot about
federer's personality and the doll you
know good-looking suave dude i don't
know much about joker let me tell you
i've watched this guy's interviews and
to me
i i look forward to his interviews
i look forward to his interviews
because
like you can feel the level of intensity
and commitment to his craft and when he
loses or makes a mistake like one time
he hit the ball i don't know he hit the
person on the side i don't know what it
was the situation and i apologize
he felt like crap in the interview
afterwards like he was like
and it wasn't a big deal but he was like
it could you and you could felt feel the
sincerity i don't know he got booted out
of that tournament yeah i know he did
yeah i remember that i i know he did and
he said i deserved it like he didn't
even come out and like you know dak
prescott yesterday's like uh yeah i was
a referee they threw you know whatever
they threw stuff at the referee this guy
took responsibility for his actions i
think the fact that he
listen if you got covet
you're this big of a name you can't go
to a place not tell people you've got
did he have covenant i mean he tested
positively i don't know he's still
unreliable he had no symptoms you know
he's got no symptoms at all he does have
covered
yeah by the way here's the flip side of
it here's a flip side of it how many
flights you think you're on
and people who are on flights have
covered it could be the person sitting
next to you you don't think people get
on flights that have coveted anyways
your thoughts we'll go to the next
subject after your thoughts here tell us
bro
the most famous moment of michael
jordan's career is when he had a highly
contagious virus and he had 103 freaking
fever and he went out and won game six
the flu game that's a great it's the flu
game yep
this dude was highly contagious and was
praised
for going for fighting through it how
many people did the evil michael jordan
bring up a really good pose to influenza
it's a different time it's a different
time where the wrong people have the
microphone we've got to tell these
people to shut up
anybody that from from australia that's
allowing their government to do this
you you're this is on you i've never met
anybody from australia that was this
type of person everybody from australia
i've met was a man's man loved freedom
hardcore same thing with canada every
canadian i ever met was an awesome
awesome hard-working freedom loving
person
and you're letting these tyrants take
over your country
like this that's what i'm saying the
rules are stupid man the rules are
dude we're not allowed to say mass
formation psychosis we're not allowed to
say it right but maybe we can say
collective munch hounds and syndrome
everybody's a threat to everybody now
everybody's sick everybody's a threat to
your well-being this is complete and
total dude this is one of the
healthiest human beings on earth
literally quantifiably one of the most
healthy human beings on earth and you
won't let him into your country because
he's a threat to your physical
well-being what type of crazy
world are we living in now right this is
outrageous yeah the only thing i would
tell you is the only thing i would tell
you is if
you're in a time like this at this level
of sensitivity in a country that's the
most sensitive
you you you have to take slightly a
different approach you don't have to
play the tournament don't show up these
are the rules they created okay you
can't go and say for example like what
you're saying to me
we're probably more on the same page on
what you're saying but this is australia
this is their rules if that's what
they're doing if you knew i don't know
the story if he knew or not that's the
part about the story with him and aaron
rodgers are kind of similar by the way a
little bit of kudos to nfl for not doing
anything to the guy that tells you as
much as roger godell and nfl gets a lot
of heat good for them he's going to win
the mvp well what i'm saying is well
some of them are counting i don't know
if you've been following stories lately
they're saying brady may want it i think
it's rogers as mvp but they may give it
to brady but if you think about how
godel this kind of validates maybe the
nfl is doing a little bit better job
than we thought they're doing than
tennis especially for australia anyway
the next thing up is the french open and
it's going to be the same thing again
you didn't see the story that they said
they may not let them play in the
friendship they may not right yeah
exactly wimbledon is going to be
same-sex crazy to me you're saying
that's the next place
yeah well there's a lot of french
there's gonna be things because that's
not till may right so keep in mind i
think there's a there's an event in
dubai in the next few months there's a
miami open in march it's the people's
though we'll see what happens with that
it's on the people it's on the people of
australia it's on the people of france
it's on the people to say enough's
enough this is nonsense just just a
quick comment too about your your his
reputation you know like i i mean i
follow the sport pretty closely i i know
a lot of people who don't like him and
who have kind of gotten that same
feeling like he's not a very likable guy
um whether that plays into this or not
and people are just out together i'm
cool with it i'm just saying not as
likable as federer yeah maybe not um you
know federer for a long time got real
cocky remember federer started walking
out with a vest that had like his
initials on it like and he was the
greatest he's number one on his shoes
you know like you got him
he was but there was a lot of arrogance
there djokovic has never done that he's
never called himself you know the
greatest and worn number one on his
shoes and all that i've seen him
overturn calls that the umpire made in
his opponent's favor because he saw it
was clearly in when the umpire called it
well he was up 6-1
this is bigger than novak djokovic this
is they made an example out of him to
show the rest of the country who's in
charge and show the rest of the world
they won't want to lose they're in
charge they want to win this is the
thing and this is this is i was just out
of miami and i did my whole thing on my
story and it was like here's the truth
of the matter man like we all have to
make a decision even if you're on that
team quote unquote if i want to go to a
restaurant in new york city do i really
have to show a permission slip from the
democratic party that i'm that i'm i'm
obedient enough to eat because let's
just say let that that's what it is
that's what the vax pass is it's a
permission slip to the elites that i'm
on board
i i think may i
please have a slice of pizza please
i'm okay with the democrats like
how can you be okay with this but but
again again here's what it goes back to
jeddah diabeela was sitting right here
when she said
let them sink
i don't have a lot of money but the
little money that i have i'm going to
pick it up and leave
people like that are making a decision
and
gerard
you know when you pick up a bad habit
how long does it take until you realize
it says this bad habit is ruining your
life uh ten years or so
but watch what you just said i'm
actually being very serious with you
think about it we all have had a bad
habit they got a hold of us i had a bad
habit that got ahold of us how hold of
me how long does it take until you
realize it's going to hurt you well how
long do you do you realize that it's
going to hurt you but then after
the longer it goes the longer it takes
to fix it man but but again but how long
until you realize there's a there's a
consequence to this battle there's a
difference between realizing it and
actually doing something about it though
yeah i realize it and the guys
became scientists
but just one other thing here what if
the other players what if nadal instead
of saying these are the rules you got to
follow what if nadal has said you know
what i'm not playing the australian open
if they don't let djokovic play
and then if it like dominoes other guys
there's no tournament
great freaking point then they would
have to say you know what let the guy
play he's healthy yeah i thought that
was you know in the nba but do you know
who did that in the nba kevin durant
yeah kyrie irving did he stand with him
he did he says i'm never gonna ask him
to do it yeah i support my teammate yeah
kevin durant and guess what the nba
finally said all right let him play on
the road yeah but the difference is he
actually played and he's been dominating
he's been mvp type caliber durant now
he's out for a month though
but
but to seth's point if durant said look
i i'm gonna stand with kyrie and if he
can't play i can't play now if literally
the league's potential mvp is saying i'm
also not going to play and half the
players stand with them have weight they
have power people this is this goes but
they don't basketball too much they're
not going to try to get into the if
they're not getting paid it applies
everywhere if we all stand up to tyranny
together then they can't push us around
anymore it's when everybody's compliant
and everybody's feeling that pressure
because every 99 of people are going
along with it you stand out when
djokovic stands up and stands against it
he stands out he's the one that they can
strike down let me ask you a question
how many of you guys listening be honest
hear me out this is the part that i love
capitalism and competition you have no
idea how much i trust competition okay
how many of you are thinking about in
2022 family vacation straight up you're
going to australia anybody
you know everybody i'm so inspired you
know
that's what's a great point
let's go
no you're not going to go to no
australia even if you're waxed no one's
outside bro like what am i going to do
in australia the other day i got a i got
a text from a guy on a cruise ship he's
on a cruise ship there's a 150 people on
a cruise ship that fits four thousand
he's like here's me having breakfast
with four other people literally he
recorded the whole thing nobody what are
you going on a cruise ship for to be
alone or go to freaking different places
there's there's there's a price to be
paid there's your next battle on b
headline not enough there's not enough
tourists to leave five stars so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]